in this lesson we're going to talk about
proportions so proportions is something
that's tested on the act that you
understand the concept and you know how
to work with proportions so let's go
through the basic concept and then we'll
do some examples so first of all what's
a proportion well proportion is a ratio
equal to another ratio a ratio is just a
fraction where you're comparing two
quantities and it's equal to another
fraction where you're comparing two
quantities now when you solve
proportions what you can do is you can
use this cross multiplying technique so
you multiply on the diagonals this
diagonal multiplied together a d equals
this diagonal multiplied together bc and
then what that does that eliminates the
fractions makes it easier to solve okay
so let's go through some examples and
we'll uh
talk about how to solve these problems
so see if you can do this on your own
pause the video and then we'll go
through it so if the amount of medicine
needed is proportional to a person's
body weight
how much medicine is required for a 180
pound person if a 120 pound person
requires 10 grams of medicine now they
won't always tell you that you know it's
proportional they might just start
setting up the problem and it's up to
you to recognize that hey this is a
proportion
okay so but the main thing here you want
to do is you want to make sure that you
set up uh let's see
a hundred and twenty pound person okay
requires ten grams of medicine so a
hundred and eighty pound person would
require x grams now the important thing
is yeah i have pounds to grams pounds to
grams you don't wanna have pounds to
grams and then switch these so you want
to be comparing you know apples to
apples or you know apples to oranges
apples to oranges you want to compare
them in the same order now i can switch
this around i could say 10 grams is to
120 pounds
as
x grams is to 180 pounds i can do it
like that if i take the reciprocal of
both sides but in any case what we're
going to do is we're going to solve this
now when you solve it
you don't have to worry about you know
these units as much okay you can just
focus on the numbers but what i'm going
to do is i'm going to reduce a little
bit before i cross multiply so i can see
that if i divide both of these by 10 i
have 12 over 1. now when i cross
multiply i get 12x equals 180 and if i
divide by 12
you can see that x is going to be
let's see 15 grams
okay now you can use your calculator you
don't have to reduce like this you can
just cross multiply and then solve okay
let's look at example number two so it
says if a circle graph or like a pie
graph basically has a central angle okay
and one of its sectors has a central
angle of 45 degrees okay how many people
does that sector represent if there are
200 people in this study okay so
basically they're setting up this
problem in such a way that we're trying
to find out how many people are in this
sector this section of the circle
if there's 200 people total so how would
you do that one see if you can solve
that one
now the reason this is a proportion is
because
see 45 degrees is to 360 degrees the
whole circle right
as
x people is to the total number of
people in the study which is 200 people
so what i have is i have the part to the
hole
equals the part to the whole okay so all
we have to do now is cross multiply and
solve but what i'm going to do is i'm
going to reduce this a little bit so 45
goes into 360 eight times so i reduce it
to one over eight now when i cross
multiply i get eight times x equals one
times 200 and if i divide both sides by
8 i get x equals 25 people
so
proportion is definitely something you
want to understand when you're taking
the math portion of the act review this
if you need to and i'll see you in the
next lesson